this is sal khan of the khan academy and
i got these questions from the brazilian
magazine super interesante and i don't
speak portuguese that well but i assume
it means super interesting so i hope i
can i can meet their standards and be at
least somewhat interesting and so they
sent me these questions and i'm just
going to give my best attempt to answer
it so question number one actually let
me use my pen tool sal style or khan
academy style to mark what question i'm
on right now so let's start with
question number one
do you see khan academy as a modern
complement to traditional education or a
resource that can be adopted without any
other tool would that be the death of
textbooks so first let's let's take the
first part because the second part's a
little little controversial do you see
khan academy as a modern compliment to
traditional education
yes i do i think
the ideal use case for the khan academy
is someone has a
an amazing teacher and and ideally
amazing peers as well
and they can go to a physical
environment and they can work with their
amazing teacher and amazing peers and
what happens
from our material is that they can watch
it at their own pace do the exercise at
their own pace and they would get data
on themselves and their awesome teacher
and and peers will get data and then
they can use that data to organize
classroom time in a more interactive way
so that everyone can really
focus on helping addressing everyone's
problems and at least in our minds it
really liberates the teacher to form a
lasting bonds and really a mentor and
and work with and and solve the problems
that the the students are having uh with
with that material and it allows the two
the students to teach each other the
second part of it would that be the
death of textbooks uh this is an
interesting question
i i guess it depends what you view
textbooks as being for uh right now i
think in in most classes the textbooks
play two roles one role is to introduce
you to the material uh with the idea
that you know in a lot of classes i've
been in the professor would say hey why
don't you go home do some of the reading
and then well that will be covered in
lecture um for that use case i think
on-demand video whether it's khan
academy or other on-demand video is
better than a lot of the the the the
text that
is may or may not that can or or cannot
be read by a lot of students uh it's
it's much easier to get it through on
demand video than trying to parse
through that text especially when you're
unfamiliar with the concept uh the other
thing that a textbook is for is is
practice that that's where a textbook is
really different than a traditional book
is that it has these practice problems
in it and uh
you know what what khan academy has is
practice problems as well but we're
collecting data on them the teacher the
student knows how they did uh how long
it took them what they're having
a weakness in or what they're what
they're strong in um and and the student
gets instant feedback they know what
they what they're understanding they
know they're not understanding and they
also get we steps that we we at least
hope explain to the student where they
might have messed up maybe they made a
careless mistake or maybe uh got the
conceptual error that they might have
had trouble and of course it's all tied
to the videos
and most textbooks right now don't give
that level of data to the student or the
to the teacher or the parents or anyone
else
and they don't even give that much
feedback they might have the answers to
half the questions in the back of the
book some have a little bit more than
that
but but not much more so in those roles
we think that on-demand video with
self-paced software with feedback and
data can can um can do a lot of those
and it's even better when it's free and
it doesn't weigh 10 pounds but with that
said i don't think i don't think
textbooks are going to completely
disappear i think they're going to be
really useful as a reference
i have a bunch of textbooks that i'm
staring at right now on my shelf and i
treasure them and uh um yeah i think
they'll be a really useful reference but
um
it's not clear whether you're going to
have generations and generations of
students having to buy
you know the new version of the textbook
every few years especially for for
subjects that are not changing on a
regular basis uh
that and and it's also clear whether
physical textbooks are probably
not going to be in the mainstream
there's already a lot of people doing
e-textbooks but i assume that this uh
this question is addressing e and
physical textbooks
question number two
if children study at home and only go to
school to do exercises teachers presence
may become less important
would they have some kind of a
consultant role instead of being someone
who explains the concepts
so i'll address the first part if
children study at home and only go to
school to do exercises teachers presence
may become less important and so this is
something that i'll actually i'll
disagree strongly with i think
imagine if we were doing the other way
imagine that the world was a world where
when kids went to class
they had deep interactions with their
peers and more importantly with or maybe
equally importantly with the teacher
where they went to class the teacher
knew who they were the teacher knew
everything about the student interacting
with the student mentoring the student
the teacher knew exactly what what the
tripping points were the student how to
how to phrase um how to phrase
information specifically for that in for
that student knowing what that student's
context is
and then all of a sudden i were to go
into that classroom and say no teacher
you have to stop doing this mentorship
this direct one-on-one instruction with
students and what i want you to do is
not have these conversations with
students anymore and what i want you to
do is go to the front of the room and i
want to get i want you to give these
lectures that are essentially these one
pace one size fits all lecture and i
want you to really it'll be essentially
the same lecture that every teacher in
the country is giving and that you've
given
years before that would be making the
teacher less important because you would
you would have taken them as a human
being as someone who understands what's
going on the student kind of the doctor
for the student's knowledge and then you
would be turning them into a broadcast
mechanism and so we're doing the exact
opposite right now unfortunately a lot
of teachers want to be that mentor a lot
of the teachers want to use class time
for interaction and creativity but right
now they have to move the entire class
at the same pace and they have to give
that that lecture
many times with very little interaction
with the students and so what we're
saying is no that that can happen at the
student's own time and at the student's
own pace and then the teacher just
becomes every minute of this of time
with the teacher just becomes with this
valuable nugget uh some of the classes
that we're piloting
the teachers are spending one of the
teachers is making a point to spend 15
minutes one-on-one with every student
per week at least and i can remember
years that i went by never getting 15
minutes one-on-one with a teacher and
that happens to many many students so we
think if anything it's making the
teachers far more important they need
they're forming bonds they have to have
a better grasp of all of the information
now because you have students working at
their own pace and it's really taking
them up the value chain because they're
no longer giving the same lecture year
in a year out
and then the second part of the question
would they have some kind of a
consultant role instead of being someone
who explains the concepts so what i
would say is that they're still
explaining the concepts but they explain
the concepts given all of the
information that they now have about the
student given the fact that that student
has already maybe watched our videos has
already done exercises that the teacher
can now act on the data based on those
video those video
coming from those videos and those
exercises so uh once again i think the
teacher has moved up the value chain
they're now more valuable for that
student than they were as a pure
lecturer
question number three
when children have the freedom to study
by themselves at home surrounded by
other appeals such as internet social
media and also the possibility just to
ignore the lessons isn't it too much
confidence in their passion for learning
don't you think some discipline is
necessary to make them study instead of
doing anything else so there's a couple
of ways to think about it right now in a
traditional in a traditional classroom
you have mostly lecture going on maybe a
little bit of other things and then all
the problem solving all the homework
happens at home
and
i agree some students might not have the
motivation to do it at home and we see a
lot of kids skipping out homework or
even the ones that do have the
motivation might not have the help and
so in my mind where the real learning
happens is actually when you're trying
to do the problem solving and what's
happening right now is when that a lot
of students are skipping out on the
problem solving on the doing the
homework either because of distractions
or
because they have no one to help them
and then they all go to a room together
where they they're in the same room but
they're all passively listening to a
lecture
we think if you had to if you had to
drop one thing from that equation make
sure the problem solving occurs make
sure that the teacher sees students do
problems don't don't don't put that out
for homework where it may or may not
happen and if you had to and i we
wouldn't advocate this but we think if
you had to pick between doing homework
and lecture which one do you skip
frankly the lecture is i think the one
that's more optional in fact some
students and we've seen this in some of
our pilots you show them enough examples
or their peers can teach them how to do
something they don't necessarily even
need to see the lecture if they see a
few examples of it that's enough and
maybe they'll go back and get watch the
lecture for for more depth or for for
more intuition on the on the subject but
with that said on top of that uh we we
don't want to just completely let it up
to the student's judgment and and have
this the teacher guessing when they come
to class the next day whether or not the
students watched lectures or did some of
the problems and so that's why we're so
focused on the data that's why we're so
focused on right now the teacher does
get a real-time dashboard and
in a traditional classroom the teacher
just sees who turned in their homework
or who did the homework and who knows if
they copied it from another student they
don't know how long it took the students
to do the homework whether they got it
right or wrong they don't know what time
of day they did the homework now the
teacher will know everything now the
teacher knows what videos the student
watched where do they even pause the
videos
what what videos did they have to repeat
they'll see what the spread of where
every student in the class is
they'll see what what problems the kid
actually did how long it took them when
they did the those problems early on
when i was doing this i saw one of my
cousins was doing all of their problems
at two in the morning that by itself was
probably big more information that they
were awake at two in the morning than
the fact that they were even getting
some of those problems wrong that's
something that a human being can then
intervene in and so
you know going back to the too much
confidence no no now we're arming
everyone with a lot more data so it's
actually it's de-risking the though just
putting it all on the student to do
everything at home
question number four let me scroll down
a little bit
and the possibility to learn in your own
wouldn't contribute to isolate shy and
misfit kids so once again complete
opposite and some people might be
surprised to hear this but i was
actually very very shy especially in
elementary and to some degree in middle
school and i felt very very isolated in
my classrooms when i was in a classroom
with 30 kids even when i had a question
i was afraid to raise my hand and i
think this is true of many many many
kids you don't want to embarrass
yourself raising it's usually the most
outgoing kids who are willing to raise
their hand usually the two or three most
outgoing kids and so i was never willing
to do that and so i if i didn't
understand something i would just put it
on myself to go home and try to struggle
with it somehow i had my my sister who
often helped me with things but i felt
very isolated and also because i was shy
you know i there would be 30 kids in the
room but i really only knew maybe five
of them well maybe because they sat near
me so i was sitting class and this is
even true in college i used to sit in
classes in college where there's 100
people in the room and i only knew two
of them and i would sit in i would sit
in that room for the whole semester and
i would never get to meet any of them
the way the traditional model works and
frankly the professor never knew who i
was and that even happened in some of my
my uh elementary and middle school and
high school where i don't really think
that perfect the teacher knew who i was
and so what we're saying is the exact
opposite
what we're saying is now you're using
the class time for the students to
actually interact with each other and so
if you look at these pilots that were
running in los altos you have all of the
students interacting with all of the
students you don't have these little
clicks where certain kids only hang out
with other kids and ignore the rest you
have them all helping each other and it
actually gives an outlet for the shy
kids maybe the shy kids who perform a
little bit better academically to
actually
gain
confidence by teaching their peers their
their peers start to respect them more
not just this shy kid who happens to do
good at school but like wow that kid
helped me and so we're seeing way more
interaction way more there's no kid
who's just hiding during the lecture and
just pretending to understand the
relation everyone is interacting the
teachers are interacting with the
students the students are interacting
with each other so we think it's the
exact opposite we think we're taking the
isolation that the shy
kids are feeling right now and we're
having them actually interact with each
other in a human experience in the
classroom
question number five do you believe that
some old-fashioned thinkers just don't
accept an education system that is
supposed to be cool
um
not 100 sure how to answer that question
i guess the assumption here is that what
we're proposing is cool i i think it is
um you know i think any any time there's
change there's always be there's all
there'll always be resistance and i
think that's a healthy thing people
should actively question things and you
no one should adopt something just
because just because it's you know
supposed to be cool or just because it
sounds cool you shouldn't just accept it
because it sounds cool and you also
shouldn't just reject it because it
sounds cool the reality is that you
really should see whether it's working
you should see whether it's working on
multiple levels subjectively how are the
teachers and the students liking it how
is the energy level and you should also
look at it objectively how is their how
is their performance changing
so you know there definitely are
knee-jerk reactions against new things
and there are knee-jerk reactions for
new things and and neither of those are
are are are the best ways to approach
you really should just have an open mind
to anything and seeing if it and see if
it really works
question number six how has the
acceptance to khan academy i was been in
the united states has bill gates of
support helped to open some conservative
doors
so you know we're still in the early
days uh khan academy once again
it started as a very grassroots thing i
started it for my cousins it was adopted
not because
a governor or the president told people
to adopt it or superintendent did it it
was adopted because students chose to
use it students on their own students
who happened to bump into it on the
internet found it useful so it was a
very grassroots thing and only later
once we had significant traction and i'd
been doing this for five or six years
did it start to get on the radar of some
of some fairly prominent people many of
those who have supported us now
including bill gates and google and
others and so um in terms of the
acceptance of the concept of the u.s you
know uh
the people who have chosen it to adopt
it naturally like it they made the
decision to use it and we haven't forced
it on anyone else and i think that's a
really important thing because i don't
think when anyone forces anything on
anyone
they tend to not like it so but so far
the acceptance has been very good and
we've had really um fascinating
experiences and tremendous results with
the pilots that chose to adopt it if we
talk about the formal setting and if you
think about the informal setting the
students who are just using it
independently i encourage anyone to go
to our youtube page or our facebook page
and and just
read the the the commentary from from
students and even ask them questions
contact them and see how it's how it's
helped them and i think you'll you'll
see that at least we like to think it's
it's profoundly uh affecting a lot of a
lot of students in the us and the world
frankly the question has bill gates
support help to open some conservative
doors you know i think that's a mixed
question a mixed answer i think it's
definitely given validation within
certain circles i think people in
silicon valley really respect having
about you know the google is behind us
bill gates is behind us these are
obviously groups and people who are
obviously intelligent who've obviously
been successful who obviously understand
what a math and science education is for
who are almost the uh the examples of
what of of you know the people at google
understand you know there's no better
application of math and science than
what google has done or what bill gates
has done or what other people in silicon
valley have done so that's that's
definitely validation um
whether it opens conservative doors not
clear because i think you know bill
gates is has also been doing other
things he's very open he's very active
in the charter movement he's he's he's
been pushing for other things um and and
so uh there are some people who react
against that and uh you know they might
be tempted to throw us in the same bag
uh but um you know us personally we try
to not take an opinion on that we we
want to be useful for anyone whether
they are
in any organization and and so you know
we we we're not taking a political
stance there but i think because
bill gates really is one of our biggest
supporters uh you know some some groups
are more receptive to it and some groups
are are less receptive to it but overall
i i mean i definitely think it's it's
been it's been a huge positive because i
think the parents and the students view
it as a huge plus when you know someone
whom they respect um thinks so highly of
it and uses it himself and uses it for
his kids
and so question number seven
has khan academy ever been contacted by
some brazilian school or company
interested in adopting its methods um i
can't say
no totally we've had a lot of contact
with people from brazil and we are
actively translating the video content
to portuguese
so we've had we've had contact with
brazil we're not doing any formal pilots
in brazil i uh i wouldn't be surprised
if some students or teachers are using
it independently in fact i'm sure
student some students are and
teachers can use what we're doing in los
altos on their own but we don't have any
formal pilots in brazil right now
question number eight
besides the positive testimonies from
los altos teachers do you have some
numbers that could measure how khan
academy has helped students
to develop some numbers that can help us
compare traditional education to your
system's performance
so the simple answer is yes we do have
numbers and this is why los altos has
decided to
go
district-wide with this in the fifth and
sixth grade actually let me pause the
video and let me let me get you some of
those numbers hold on one second
so you asked for data so here's data
that i got and this we have other data
but this this one piece of data is
probably the most compelling that really
convinced los altos and it's not a
rigorous study and we're going to be
doing more rigorous studies this year
with larger data sets and in a more
controlled way but uh you know we
obviously had all of the anecdotal
higher energy in the classroom kids were
more engaged the teachers loved it but
we wanted to see real data so this is
actually what we saw out of the seventh
grade pilots and i want to be clear
these seventh grade classes were
they were considered developmental
classes classes kids that weren't
tracked with the normal students they
were held back they weren't performing
at grade level and this shows how they
performed at their their their district
standard exam standardized exam in 2010
and you can see that uh the best
students here you had 23 that were that
were proficient then you had 47 that
were basic 23 that were below basic and
then you had six that were far below
basic don't get this light blue confused
with this dark blue over here because
they're saying very different things so
this is far below so this right over
here they're not they're not doing well
far below basic the six and so the same
students after doing khan academy for
about six or seven months and once again
it's hard to separate how much the
courtney caldwell is who's the teacher
here is just an off the charts awesome
teacher so it might be due to her as
well uh but what we've seen but you know
she herself expressed that the energy
level that she saw in the class is very
unusual for for especially a class that
is at this developmental stage
these are the results from this year's
standardized exam so uh
there's no there's there's no longer any
students in this group that are far
below basic and in fact there are now
six kids that are advanced so just to be
clear these are kids that have now
left leapfrog their peers who are not
placed in this class so normally when
you're tracked into a slower class
that's usually the end of your math
career you're usually just going to
drift further and further behind the
other students these students after half
a year actually got did better than many
students who weren't placed into the
slower class and then you have many many
more students who are now proficient the
the basic you still have 47 but you have
so many more proficient or advanced and
then you have no students that are far
below basic and 12 of the pilot students
moved from being below basic to
proficient 12 and 6 percent moved from
moved from far below basic to basic so
we we have a general there's a general
trend where people just where people
just moved forward so this was a big one
we have other data and we're hoping to
get a lot more data this year
and then once again not a rigor study so
not something that we can publish in a
scientific journal but that with all of
the anecdotal evidence made made los
altos feel feel pretty good and made us
feel pretty good and and we and we don't
consider this a done deal we consider
ourselves that
we're just in the first inning and we
have to constantly improve this thing so
that we can get even better results next
year and then the year after that
question number nine do you believe
children should have the opportunity to
use other new technologies in schools
such as mobile phones ipods and podcasts
i think it's like everything it's if
it's used in a proper context and yes if
it's helpful and if it's not helpful
maybe no and but we should have an open
mind about what helpful is or what it
isn't and just try things out and and
adjust accordingly
question 10 are films the new books
do you think that a culture focused on
images has contributed the notion that
books are boring
um
films you know on some level they are
you know even before khan academy shows
up films have always been a a form of of
of book but you know people still like
to read the book and then watch the film
uh the books give you more depth give
you more nuance but the films are still
fun i don't think it's a culture focused
on images that contribute to the notion
that books are boring i think there are
books that are amazing and fascinating
and some of my best experiences in life
are from reading some of those amazing
books
but there are books that are boring and
it doesn't hurt if we can find a medium
that is less boring so i think it really
depends from case to case and i don't
think it's just this generation i think
if you've taken any generation and if
you'd given them something that's less
boring or a better way or a more
intuitive way or more approachable way
to understand something you know they
would have found it equally equally
compelling